in our morning rounds scientists in the
united states have successfully repaired
a faulty gene in human embryos for the
first time researchers use the powerful
technology known as CRISPR to fix the
DNA mutation that causes an inherited
form of heart disease 72% of the
resulting embryos were disease-free none
were implanted the experiment shows it
is possible to prevent the defect from
being passed to future generations
in 2015 we spoke to Jennifer Doudna the
scientist who helped develop the
technology think about a film strip you
know and you see a particular segment of
the film that you want to replace you
could go in and sniff out a piece and
replace it with something that corrects
a mutation that would cause disease our
doctor David agus is in Los Angeles good
morning doctor put aside some of the
questions about the ethical issues here
on a purely scientific basis how big of
a breakthrough is this Wow human genetic
gearing genetic engineering yesterday
was science fiction and today it's
reality so they took eggs from normal
eggs from women and they injected them
with sperm from a man that had
hypertrophic cardiomyopathy this is when
high school athletes push themselves and
they have sudden death this is that gene
defect and they also injected CRISPR
caspase-9 and what it does is it
searches out the one error in the 3
billion letters of the DNA code it chops
it out and the DNA corrects itself and
so in 72% of the embryos they did it it
worked 3 days later they sacrificed the
embryos that were fertilized but this
was an experiment showing this was
possible is the exciting thing here that
the gene corrects itself part of it is
it corrects itself and part of it is the
potential of what can be done here is
that this technology was originally
discovered in bacteria and now clearly
works in human cells in these embryos
and it's viable what looks like from
these experiments is that it was precise
the other 3 billion letters weren't
touched so doctor a gizmo
pointed this out there are some ethical
concerns and implications with this what
are they and how will they be addressed
well you know this is the beginning of a
new frontier so we can change DNA in an
embryo sir early onset Alzheimers cystic
fibrosis sickle cell anemia could be
diseases of the past but at the same
time where's the line what do you wanna
catch I'll die faster blue or I blonder
hair the potential for eugenics this
really is something that needs to be
discussed the problem is who's in charge
of it who makes it decisions and who
decides on the rules and regulations no
question and if we decide here in the
United States also want us to do is get
on a plane and go to Mexico go to South
America go somewhere else this is a
small lab in order to do this this is
not that complex give me one give me one
example of what might be possible in the
next five years well in the next five
years people with HIV now we could take
out their immune cells and change them
so the virus can't get in the receptor
ccr5 can be changed and so all of a
sudden HIV patients will not develop
AIDS
Wow this is Wow I didn't even think
about how many lives would have been
sold saved if we could have known that
10 years ago 15 years ago no question
about it but it's here and so the
challenge is to do it right thank you
David thank you